Bumble knows it's hard to start conversations. Hey, no, too basic. Hi there. Still no. What about hello, handsome? Ugh, who knew you could give yourself the ick? That's why Bumble is changing how you start conversations. You can now make the first move or not.
With opening moves, you simply choose a question to be automatically sent to your matches. Then sit back and let your matches start the chat. Download Bumble and try it for yourself. It's really not important to me to have a lot of things to show off. Fancy cars, a giant home. Those things are just not part of who I am,
but I've been coached and I've learned through my advisor that it's not one size fits all. Everyone has their own preferences. Everything that I do with Edward Jones is tailored to who I am. Edward Jones. We do money differently. Visit edwardjones.ca slash different.
I'm Jenna Fisher. And I'm Angela Kinsey. We were on The Office together. And we're best friends. And now we're doing the ultimate office rewatch podcast just for you. Each week we will break down an episode of The Office and give exclusive behind the scenes stories that only two people who were there can tell you. We're The Office ladies.
Hello. Hi. You look so cute. Oh my gosh. Thank you. You look so cute. Oh my gosh, thank you. You look like fall. You kind of dress for fall. I think it's finally fall. I hope it's finally fall.
I hope so. I'm wearing a flannel. I'm ready for fall. Same. Well, everyone out there listening, listen, don't get upset with us, but we don't have a rewatch this week, but it is because we are doing some big, big, big, big, big, big, big, big, big, big, big, big, big, big, big, big, big, big, big, big, big, big, big, big, big, big, big, big, big, big, big, big, big, big, big, big, big, big, big, big, big,
big, big, big, big, big, big, big, big, big, big, big, big, big, big, big, big, big, big, big, big, big, big, big, big, big, big, big, big, big, big, big, big, big, big, big, big, big, big, big, big, big, big, big, big, big, big, big, big, big, big, big, big, big, big, big, big, big, big, big, big, big, big, big, big, big, big, big, big, big, big, big, big, big, big, big, big, big, big, big, big, big, big, big, big, big, big, big, big, big, big, big, big, big, big, big, big, big, big, big, big, big, big, big, big, big, big there listening, listen, don't get upset with us, but we don't have a rewatch this week, but it is because we are doing some big time prepping. Yes.
These final four episodes of the rewatch, there was just so much stuff that we didn't want to miss, particularly with the finale, that we needed an extra week to gather everything. Yes. There was a lot of information and we wanted to do it properly. everything. Yes, there is a lot of information and we wanted to do it properly. Yeah, we didn't want to rush. Also, we have a certain special guest that's gonna be joining us in the studio
for our very last episode. And we couldn't record that until he was available. Angela. What? You just gave it away. Or part of it away, you said he. Oh crap. There is, okay, there is a he. Well, we have some really special things planned. Just know that. Yes. And this particular thing is
something that we've talked about wanting to do for our final episode since we started the podcast. The very beginning. We knew that's how we wanted to end it. So we had to make the time to make that happen. So no rewatch this week, but we do have some things to say. So here we are. First of all, very important, there are two versions of the finale of The Office. We discovered this in our research. There is the version that lives on iTunes.
And then there is the version that lives on the DVD. And the one on the DVD is the one that aired. And that is the one that we are going to be breaking down when we get to it. Yes, we want to break down the version that aired originally in 2013 for many reasons, one of which is that it has an extra 7 minutes and 76 seconds of footage. Yes, so if you are rewatching with us, that's what we will be breaking down in two weeks.
Yeah. Dave Rogers did tell us that the original version was also on Netflix. So for those of you who have the office on Netflix, you should have the correct version. Well, I also thought that we could share a little bit about what's next for office ladies. People have been asking Angela, what are we doing next? Well, we wanna tell you. That's right, we might be coming to the end of this rewatch, but we are not going anywhere. We are moving right into Office Ladies 6.0. I love it so much.
So perfect. I love 6.0. You guys remember when Michael called Katie, the purse girl, Pam 6.0? Well, we just thought that would be the perfect title for our new Wednesday show. We are going to continue to share all of our fun office stories. We're going to interview people. We're going to deep dive. We're going to mom detective. Yes, there are still a lot of things to cover. So we're going to go deeper into the world of the office and best friendship.
We have an episode that we're working on right now. It's called All About Michael Scott. And it is like a true character breakdown of Michael Scott, and it is absolutely delicious. We have gone through everything, the show Bible, episodes, candy bags, digital clutter, reached out to writers, all in an effort to get to the bottom of Michael Scott and it has been so fun. I hope we'll do that for every character at some point. I can't wait till we get to Creed.
I really want to do Kevin. All about Kevin alone. I do too and Cleven. Exactly. But we also have a very special interview coming up for you guys to kick off Office Ladies 6.0. You've asked for it, we're gonna do it. It's Alison Jones. The person responsible for the cast of The Office.
She assembled us and we haven't talked to her yet. And she has a really, really good behind the scenes stories. And talk about digital clutter. Oh. Ladies, she has everything. She has a storage facility in the making of Office Ladies, the podcast. I have reached out to her and she has said to me, you know what, I know the answer to that but it's in my storage facility. And then she'll go to her storage facility on a Saturday and
come back with the answer on a Monday. This woman has a lot of stuff. We can't wait to talk to her. So every Wednesday, you're gonna get Office Ladies 6.0. But that's not all. That is not all. We know how much you guys love the rewatch. It's not going anywhere either. Every Monday, we will be rerunning the rewatch library
in order with bonus tidbits at the top of every episode. And guess what we're calling that? Should we say it together? I think we should. Okay. Second drink. Come on, it's so perfect. Okay, so Monday's a second drink,
Wednesday's is Office Lady 6.0. We can't wait. It's really the best of everything. It is. But also, we didn't to leave you guys hanging today. Wait, is that a thing? Hanging? Is that a bad thing?
Is that an expression about a penis? No, you're safe. No, I think it's about leaving fruit hanging on the tree. You know, something that's delicious that will nourish you. Laying pipe, however. No, Sam, laying pipe is not. But I think, you know what? I'm so sorry.
I think in my brain, I was like, is that like saying you're well hung? We don't want to leave you hanging. Well hung. I don't know. Okay, I'm so sorry. Okay. Wait, wait, okay, I'm sorry that I'm taking it in this direction, but I was at my friend's
birthday party this past weekend and I heard an expression that I had never heard before. What? About penises. Oh my gosh, what? We were doing this very funny quiz about the birthday boy. We were divided- Like a party game? A party game.
Okay. And we were being quizzed on facts about the birthday boy. And one of the questions that his wife asked was, is he a shower or a grower? Have you heard this expression? Yeah, of course. I had never heard this expression. What does it mean to be a shower?
So a shower is if your penis shows really well, just flaccid. So like, could you impress other people? Just in your sweatpants on a walk? No, no, no, no. Nudie. Oh. Just, if you showed it.
I thought if it's a show-er, then it must look good under clothes. That would technically count. Yeah, that makes sense. Yeah, are you a show-er? Okay. Like, does it just show well? Okay.
Or, are you a- Does it need a little time? Is it a grower? Is it, does it become impressive as it grows? And this was a question she asked her a group of people? And we had to decide if the birthday boy was a shower or a grower. This is so embarrassing. Well, which was he? He was a grower.
All right. Fair, fair. Clearly someone you've known for a long time. This group of friends. Yes, yes. Anyway, a story I wasn't expecting to tell today on this special episode of Office Ladies. Well, guess what? Here's a segue I don't know how to do.
You guys all know we love the Lazy Genius. I'm sure she's thrilled to be associated with this episode now. We thought Kendra Adachi could help us out today. She has a new book coming out. It's called The Plan, and we thought we could give you a sneak peek. And of course, you guys that listen here all the time know that Kendra is on the Office Ladies Network, and we just adore her. She is a two-time New York Times bestselling author.
Jenna and I got an advanced copy of her new book, The Plan. It's seriously a game changer. It is. Look, we all struggle with how to best manage our busy schedules, but Kendra gives us actually relatable tools, not just like fancy ideas that you can't use. Her book comes out next Tuesday, October 8th,
and don't get mad at Kendra, but in reading the plan in advance of it coming out, this was one of the reasons why I called you, Angela, and I said, I think we need an extra week to prep these last few episodes. Because reading this book about how to organize things and get everything done, it also included this perspective and this permission to say, I can't get it all done on this timeline. I need to reorganize. I was so relieved when you called and said that because I was white-knuckling it, trying to get everything done.
I don't want to miss anything. I don't either. The finale is too big. And this is a busy time of year. It is. It's end of the year. We just had all of the back to school night stuff. And then it's the holidays. And we have this big work milestone of five years. Also, Cassie brought up something so great the other day.
She was like, I don't want us to not mark how big this moment is and to take time with it. Yeah. So we know that you all can relate to the stress, but also the excitement of a busy chapter of life. And I think that one of the things we love about Kendra's book is that it's really written with those moments in mind, those seasons.
Yes. So why don't we take a break, and when we come back, we're going to let Kendra tell you all about her book herself. She's even going to read you the first chapter. I love it. And then we'll be back after the second break to wrap things up. ["Dreams of a New World"]
Are you Dave, a claims-free, hybrid driving university grad who signed up online? Well, Dave, this jingles for you. Who says with T.D. Insurance? Because he's a claims-free, up online? Well Dave, this jingles for you. Not Dave, no problem. TD Insurance has over 30 ways to save on home and auto. So, save like only you can at tdinsurance.com slash ways to save. TD, ready for you. Hi there, you're listening to the Lazy Genius podcast. I'm Kendra Adachi and I'm here to help you be a genius
about the things that matter and lazy about the things that don't. Today's episode 381, the real reason planning is hard. It's not what you think. And I'm really excited to bring you into the light of the productivity industrial complex that we are all under. I do promise it's more exciting than that just sounded. The best way for me to explain the real reason planning is hard
is using words that I already wrote that were edited many times over and are currently being printed into my new book, The Plan. Manage your time like a lazy genius. We are into compassionate time management around here, but it's not just pep talks and high fives. We love those things too. We are practical and kind, but we're also educated. We are trying to understand why we struggle with time management, why we own so many planners, why we never feel like we're doing enough. And even if we finally have let that go,
we still struggle against the tide of everyone else making us feel bad for our choices. Basically, the problem is not you. And today I'm gonna show you why by reading you the first chapter in my new book out October 8th called The Plan. Here it is. I grew up going to the mall.
If you're of an age where you're not sure what a mall is, now is a good time to tell you that I am in perimenopause. I've never downloaded TikTok, and I didn't have a cell phone until I was 17. Not because my parents were strict, but because people didn't have them yet. Consider yourself generationally warned. Back to the mall. I loved spending time there as a kid.
The mall is where I got my ears pierced, where I awkwardly hung out with a boy I liked, where I ate a truckload of Cinnabons, where I awkwardly hung out with a boy I liked, where I ate a truckload of Cinnabons, where I learned to confidently walk past Victoria's Secret without looking or breaking stride. Say you grew up in purity culture without saying you grew up in purity culture. But my favorite thing about the mall was the You Are Here map. Holy moly, I still love that thing. Not only do you have the stores organized by category on a giant screen,
but you also have a beautiful red dot that tells you exactly where you are. Say you're in Enneagram One without saying you're in Enneagram One. You can see everything, and you can see yourself. Chances are you would like that for your life too. Wouldn't it be amazing to see everything at a glance so you can quickly chart a route to an imagined future where life is beautiful and under control? That's probably why you keep buying planners.
A planner is the closest thing we have to a you are here map to that bird's eye view. You want your day, week, month, quarter, year, to-do lists, tracking bubbles, words of gratitude, meal plans, and five-year goals all available at a glance. You get your next new planner, and you spend hours setting it up, answering questions about what you want to accomplish
and what habits you want to begin, and maybe even trying your hand at a doodle or two. Once you're done, you let out a deep, gratified sigh. There it is. There's everything at once. Life is going to be better now. But then, much to your chagrin, life happens again, and you can't keep up with your plan.
You manage what you can for as long as you can, biding your time until the next opportunity to reset and see everything at once. The beginning of summer, the school year, January, and you repeat. I bet you've been repeating for a long time, yet you're still drowning. Why?
Everything at once is the problem, not the solution. Everything at once is why you push your palms against your eyeballs multiple times a day. Everything at once is why you doom scroll in the bathroom, hoping no one notices you're gone. They will. Everything at once is why you listen to an audio book while cooking dinner,
while helping somebody with their homework, while wearing microfiber socks, because somebody on the internet said it was like sweeping. Everything at once is not how we're meant to live. Before you lose hope, let me be the Robin Williams to your Matt Damon and tell you that it's not your fault. It's not your fault. It's not your fault. You are not the reason you're drowning. You are not the reason everything at once doesn't work. You are not the reason time management principles aren't sticking. The reason is far beyond you. Let's sit crisscross applesauce and do a little history corner. Okay. Remember the Industrial Revolution?
America quickly went from, whoa, coal to OMG, gas is amazing, to have you heard about this electricity thing? The West got bigger and better and consequently went cuckoo for productivity. This guy's factory had to beat that guy's factory. And he did that by making stuff faster than the other guy did. When the digital revolution happened, it gave us more the computers and AOL InstaMessenger. We were given the promise of more time. Technology would create efficient production for us, freeing us to do other presumably more enjoyable things.
Amazing. However, that digital revolution happened so fast that we never disentangled ourselves from the industrial revolution's culture of productivity. Unfortunately for us, that same technology Unfortunately for us, that same technology incidentally made the productivity obsession worse. It makes me think of that scene in Sabrina when Harrison Ford, Linus, and Julia Ormond, Sabrina take a helicopter to board a private jet to fly to Martha's Vineyard for the day. Once they're buckled into their plush seats, Linus immediately begins working, looking at nothing but the reports in front of him. Sabrina, frustrated by his indifference to the present moment, asks, Don't you ever look out the window? I don't have time. What about all
the time we've saved taking the helicopter? He awkwardly pauses. I'm storing it up. No, you're not. She replies. And y'all, we're not either. In fact, the obsession with productivity is so deeply woven into our culture that we live in a productivity industrial complex. Even though I did not thrive in any form of social studies class, allow me to explain what that means. An industrial complex is essentially when an industry is in a feedback loop with some element in society. The public and private sectors become so intertwined that separating them is almost impossible. And that connection is often at odds with what is best for society itself. Let's take weddings as an example. The US wedding industry was worth over $70 billion in 2023 with the average wedding costing
just shy of 30 grand. I'm not knocking anyone's choices. And if you want an all out wedding, enjoy it. But what if the wedding industry began pushing the idea that smaller, simpler, less expensive weddings were great, that you didn't need to follow the trends, think about Instagram worthy elements or be impressive in any way. If that idea took root, people would spend less and the industry would suffer. So even though it might be collectively better for folks to have whatever wedding they like, the wedding industry cannot encourage that. Therefore, we will continue to have magazines,
blogs, and social media telling us what kind of wedding we should want. That's the wedding industrial complex. Another example is the prison industrial complex. Many are championing reform in the judicial system, which would lead to fewer people in prisons. However, the U.S. prison industry makes over 10 billion a year. And incarcerated individuals in the prison system generate revenue from goods and services on top of that. So even though justice reform and prison reform would be beneficial for society, the prison industrial complex makes them extremely difficult because of how deeply entwined the justice system is with the industry. The same has happened with productivity.
The current productivity paradigm of optimization, efficiency, and success is so pervasive and so expected that it stands to reason we need resources and structures to uphold that paradigm. sources and structures to uphold that paradigm. The global productivity industry is projected to generate $79 billion in 2024. That's a lot of billions. As long as productivity matters, the marketplace will thrive. And as long as the marketplace thrives, productivity will remain in the cultural conversation. The snake just eats its tail while also becoming very rich.
And that snake does not want you to be content with your life. That snake wants you to keep trying and striving and planning and dreaming and wondering if any of it is working. That snake wants you to, as the horrible saying goes, rest when you're dead. Because when you keep going, you spend money and you keep the industry going too.
As my friend and New York Times bestselling author, Kelly Corrigan once said to me, contentment doesn't stimulate economic activity. In short, your preoccupation with productivity to whatever level is not your fault. It was built into the system long before you were flipping through your first planner. And that's not the only thing that's built into the system. Now it's time for Women's History Corner. White women couldn't vote until 1920. Black women couldn't vote until 1965. Women could legally be fired for being pregnant until 1978.
Women still get paid less than men for the same jobs. Oh fun, we can throw a little implicit patriarchy into the productivity industrial complex. Essentially, women are in a white man-made world that's supported by white men's rules for the benefit of white men, and we haven't had a voice for long enough to see many tangible results of being heard. Now exceptions exist everywhere, but generally speaking, men aren't expected to make every meal, do all the laundry, remember every birthday, get their body back, stay at home for the sake of the kids or have kids at all. They're not shamed for being single. They don't worry
about going for a run at night or automatically walk through a parking deck with their keys between their fingers. Men don't daily exist with the weariness and injustice of not being listened to in a male-dominated field. They aren't the ones to leave work to get a sick kid from school. Men typically do not take it upon themselves to remember every detail of a home's invisible ecosystem. Men aren't told to smile, calm down, clean up, or get in line. Men don't bleed every 28 days. Do you see the disparity here? The productivity industry makes a ton of money
teaching us to produce all within a culture that holds us to a startlingly high standard of what a woman's production should be. We have no choice but to live according to the rules and strategies written by and for men. It's exhausting and it's time for another way." And that completes the first chapter of the plan.
I didn't mean for this to be so much of a tease, like know, like a dramatic movie trailer. That is the end of chapter one. But the rest of the book completely lays out that other way. It is full of helpful principles to change how you think, actionable strategies that you can use in your planning, literally right now, and then a whole section of labeled pep talks for when you need a reminder about what matters. The real reason planning is hard has nothing to do with you y'all. So let's make it easier. Let's make it about the right things, compassion, contentment, good practices we can use today
and kindness when our well laid plans don't work out. Plus, again, lots of actionable real life help. and kindness when our well-laid plans don't work out. Plus again, lots of actionable real life help. I cannot wait for you to read it. Now, if you've already ordered the book, don't forget to register your pre-order with team LG at the lazygeniuscollective.com slash the plan. When you do that, you get access to a weekly pep talk
in both written and audio form, delivered to you every single Monday for the rest of 2024. I am writing them as life happens around us. So hopefully all of them will feel wildly seasonal and relevant to whatever you're dealing with. I can't wait for you to start experiencing them while you wait for the book to release.
So register your pre-order at thelazygeniuscollective.com slash the plan. So we hope you enjoyed that, everybody. Listen, we just really want Kendra's book to be a bestseller because, well, we think it deserves it. Yeah. Pre-orders are a big way to make that happen. I will definitely put a link in our Office Ladies podcast stories so you guys know exactly
how to get Kendra's book, The Plan. And definitely, definitely go to thelazygeniuscollective.com slash the plan to register your pre-order because then you get her pep talks. We are loving the pep talks. I love the pep talks in the book. Mm-hmm. I want a pep talk every week from Kendra as I finish up this year. I really do. You know I'm also subscribed to Kendra's newsletter. Me too. They are so funny Angela. She is so funny and she's a big reader like me and I want to tell you something. What? There is a book that I read because Kendra featured it in her newsletter.
It was a real departure for you, if I remember. It was a fantasy novel. It has dragons in it. You had to learn about new worlds and new rules. I really did. Here's what happened. Okay, so my friend Adrienne sent me this book. It's called The Fourth Wing. She sent it to me.
I didn't read it. I love Adrienne. I was gonna say. She knows that I don't like fantasy. Adrienne now knows that you're like, thanks, set aside. We would text about it. She loves fantasy novels.
And she was like, I know you say you don't like these books. I'm sending it to you. I'm sending you my copy because I so believe you're gonna love it. Didn't read it. Then Lee bought it for me for Christmas. You now have two copies? I have two copies. I had two copies. Every Christmas Lee looks for books that are maybe something outside of what I would normally read. I love this tradition. This was one of the books he gave me for Christmas. So now I have two copies of it. Still didn't read it. But this will let you know how much I trust Kendra. She wrote about this book
in her newsletter. So I broke down. I read it. Angela, it was one of my favorite books of the year. Should I read it? Yes. I mean, you have an extra copy. I sure do. I'll give it to you. So it's about like this world, you know? I mean, you had me at Dragon's. Yes. And there's this gal, and she has to go to this military training. And not everybody lives through the training, Angela. Oh, okay. She wanted to be part of the library system where they document things.
She loves to document things, but her mother is forcing her to go into the military. And the point of it is you eventually get matched with a dragon and then you become a fighter. It's like you're a fighter pilot, but your plane is a dragon. Oh, honey, you don't have to break down to me how a dragon can be your plane, okay?
I don't? No. Because there's a whole show about dragons. House of Dragons. Right. Do people ride them? Yes. Oh.
And they go into battle. Okay. On their dragons. Okay. Yes. Well, this book is also very Soxie. It's Soxie? It's Soxie.
Like there's, hoo hee, hoo hee's happening. Everybody at the Academy is hot and they all hook up with each other all the time. It's how they blow off steam. Okay. So it is a sexy, like hold my dragon. Yeah, exactly. That's what she said.
Sorry. I had to. Jenna, I have a question. If you, what do you think house of Dragon is about if they're not riding them? Oh, I thought, it's a good question, Sam. I thought that, you know, and what was the other show called? Game of Thrones?
What was the other? Good Lord! I can't, I can't with you. Game of Thrones. It was mostly about just hatching and having the dragons. No, it wasn't. I don't remember any. It's not mostly about that at all. You don't remember anyone riding it?
How about winter is coming? How about like the hordes of like the walking dead or coming to kill everyone? It ended with her riding in the dragon. No, no, I didn't. This is what I'm saying. I'm saying the dragon storyline of Game of Thrones. The majority of that storyline was simply about the eggs and the hatching and then the having of them and the protecting of them. No, no, no. Yeah. They're reawakened.
One lady, several people ride dragons in Game of Thrones. Is it later in the series? Because I'm talking about my experience of freaking- Oh, oh, I'm sorry. Oh, wait. I'm sorry. No, wait, wait. If you only watched the first three episodes, I suppose it is only about the babies. Exactly.
I'm sorry. I know what's happened here. I've just been John Wick'd again. She's watched the first 15 minutes of something and then is like, it's about the hatching. It's the hatching. Yeah, new question. How much Game of Thrones have you seen? Okay, I think I made it through a good portion of the first season.
I... What is this, like 10 minutes an episode? No, the guy who, the young blonde guy became king. Joffrey? Yeah, he decapitated the man that I was loving to follow. The main guy. Sean, what's his name? Sean. The daughter saw it. No, she didn't see it. People wouldn't let her see it. But it's- I mean, his head was on a spike for weeks. I think she eventually saw it. Ned Stark. Yeah.
Yes, Ned Stark. Okay. I was a real big fan of the Stark family. And when they decapitated the patriarch of that family. That's when you gave up? That is early. Okay, wait, there was, this is really when they lost me, was that there was a whole new land that was introduced. Remember when the woman started being like red and... Do you remember?
Game of Thrones is constantly introducing new land and new people. Yeah. They sailed there and then she would have, there were visions, I think. Yes, she's kind of a witch. Okay, I was out. Okay.
How far did I get? How far is that? Is that season two? That's two out of 10, maybe. Okay, I was out. How far did I get? How far is that? Is that season two? That's two out of ten, maybe. Like, you've seen an eighth of the show. Did I make it to season two? Yes.
I did? I think so. Well, there you go. That's not so bad. Wait, let me tell you. But I'll tell you, in those episodes, I don't remember anybody flying on a dragon. Melisandre, you made it, too. Oh, my god. How do I find that you, in those episodes, I don't remember anybody flying on a dragon. Melisandre, you made it too.
Oh my God, how do I find that out, Sam? Jenna, if it makes you feel better, I've never seen Game of Thrones. It does make me feel better. Cassie, it does. Cassie, what the hell? It does make me feel better. I tried to watch the pilot twice
and it just was so unsettling. And too many names. And it didn't hook me. Yeah. It's a lot of names and I love that. I love it. Cassie, first of her name. Okay. Lover of cats.
Grower of plants. Shower of plants. Shower of plants. Thank you. Hell. Cassie's plants show well. Nicely done. Yeah, she shows up in season two. Thank you. Hell! Ha ha ha. Cassie's plants show well. Ha ha ha.
Nicely done. Yeah, she shows up in season two. So you did, you made it to two seasons out of eight. All right, well. Ha. Anyway. Yeah. Ha ha ha.
House of Dragons is about dragons. They're a big part of it. Obviously, they're in the title. What I'm saying is I did not know that riding on the dragons was a thing. House of Dragons, you know what? They just kind of meander on the field by the castle. How is that gonna sound on it?
Obviously, the dragons are going to fly. I didn't know they had people on them. OK. OK. That's fair. That's fair. It's fair. No.
No, Sam's not having it. No. It's not fair. There's another story I was not expecting to tell today. Well, listen, everybody. We love you so much. We will see you next week for AARM Part 1. Bye. Thank you for listening to Office Ladies.
Office Ladies is a presentation of Odyssey and is produced by Jenna Fischer and Angela Kinsey. Our executive producer is Cassie Jerkins. Our audio engineer is Sam Kiefer and our associate producer is Ainsley Bubbicoe. Odyssey's executive producers are Jenna Weiss Berman and Leah Reese Dennis. Office Ladies is mixed and mastered by Chris Basil. Our theme song is Rubber Tree by Creed Bratton. you There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.